en su carrera en la nfl chad pennington
tuvo dos mil 471 intentos de pase y mil
632 pases completos con base en su
record estima la probabilidad de que
chad complete un pase en su siguiente
intento suponiendo que él sigue activo
vamos a expresar la respuesta en
decimales redondeando a la centésima más
cercana
nosotros podemos saber que ha tenido mil
632 pases completos de los dos mil 471
pases que le han enviado con esto
podemos saber que su probabilidad de
completar un pase más pues será mil 632
entre dos mil 471 de acuerdo a la
información que nos han dado
vamos a hacer uno más en la temporada
2013 miguel cabrera de los tigres de
detroit estuvo al bate es quinientos
cincuenta y cinco veces y golpeó la
pelota 193 veces con base en su
desempeño estima la probabilidad de que
miguel golpeara pelotas la siguiente
ocasión que esté al bate vamos a
escribir la respuesta una vez más
calcularemos que si este hombre ha
acertado 193 pelotas o las ha golpeado
de 555 haremos la división de 193 entre
555 y eso nos dará un total de punto 34
recuerda que si vamos a redondear a
centésimas el 7 que se encuentra en las
milésimas hará que suba el número que
tenemos hacia la izquierda es decir
tendremos ahora 35 centésimos vamos a
escribir punto 35 vamos a comprobar
nuestra respuesta y es correcta